there's a lot of those films that you
try to watch today
and you go jesus i don't know if you
could ever do this like there's so many
films
that you try to watch today like i just
watched super bad the other day yeah
i'm like man i don't even know if you
could do super bad today and that's not
even that long ago
well i don't believe in that kind of
statement because the thing about it is
i think that statement is a kind of
self-fulfilling prophecy
if you say it's going to be a problem
it's going to be a problem
all right because it comes with usually
the idea well i don't know if they would
let you do that
well who the [ __ ] is they well you say
that as quentin tarantino but if you're
quentin tarantino in 1991
well okay yeah well i'm quentin
tarantino in 1991
doing reservoir dogs coming off of the
80s
which was the decade of they won't let
you do that that's true
and i remember like okay for instance
i'll give i'll give you an example so
i'm working at video archives and now by
the way
that whole horrible time and by the way
we're going through the 80s part two
right now except except there's more of
a
mccarthyist blacklist aspect to it than
than was
in the 80s the 80s seemed very people
were doing it to themselves where here
is no no people are doing it to you
um but i remember okay so in the 80s
this was only happening in america in
the other countries they were making
bold wild cinema the hong kong movies
were off the [ __ ] chart
uh pedro omotovar was like making his
wild
sex comedies amazing anyway so
pedro almonovar had a movie called
matador with antonio banderas that came
out very funny movie
the movie starts the opening credits
is a guy sitting in a chair in his
living room with his pants down around
his ankles
and he's jerking off and what he's
jerking off to
are the most bloody violent scenes in in
slasher movies
he's got like all his favorite moments
from slasher movies of women getting
murdered
all cut together and he's jerking off
and that's the opening credits
and it's just like there was like so
nothing like that available in america
they're like oh my god this is the
wildest
[ __ ] ever man this is amazing and so i
remember
like sitting at video archives and i'm
saying well i want to do [ __ ] like that
when i'm making movies and then one of
the guys said
well they won't let you quentin and my
answer was
well who's they who are they
to tell me what i can and can't do can
or cannot do
and at the end of the day the proof is
in the pudding i never let
they stop me i did what i wanted to do
and by doing what i wanted to do
we changed the 90s the 90s stopped being
politically correct and all of a sudden
like in one year
reservoir dogs el mariachi
uh man bites dog uh
romeo is bleeding i mean all these like
wild
uh er wild ironic
violent movies started coming out that
just didn't exist in 1989
um and then then come seven and then i
mean
it's like we built a bridge and then
everyone followed it everyone went over
the badge